donald trump is a multi-billionaire who
apparently
just started with one million dollars
standing at approximately two and a half
billion dollars today donald trump has
seemingly produced a 2
500 x return throughout his business
career
though that does sound impressive is
that actually
a phenomenal return or would trump have
just been better off
throwing his father's 1 million at the s
p 500
and calling it a day
well starting off we know that donald
trump set on his first construction
project
in manhattan in the year 1976
at the age of 30 years old he has
previously revealed that he received a
million dollar loan from his dad
in 1975 which means that he's had 45
years to go the million dollars to 200
billion dollars
according to him a return of 2500
over 45 years comes out to an annual
growth rate of a whopping
18.99 or nearly
warren buffett level returns of 20.5
per year but something to consider is
that donald trump has not managed his
empire himself
over the past couple of years since he
set on his presidential bid
in 2015. since 2015
donald trump has lost 2 billion due to a
variety of reasons such as
potentially poor management half of the
country not wanting to stay at his
hotels
and things like that as a result using
the two and a half billion
net worth figure isn't an accurate
representation of the returns he was
able to produce
as he nor his family have been focused
on growing the family business
over the past five years thus will focus
on the 40 years between 1975
and 2015 during which donald trump was
fully involved in the business
with that being said donald trump was
worth 4.5
billion dollars according to forbes at
the start of 2016.
this means that he was actually able to
produce a 4500x return
between 1975 and 2015.
that's an annual return of an astounding
23.404
which is higher than warren buffett but
not as high as jeff bezos 30
plus annual return during the same time
period
then s p 500 has grown on average 8.166
percent per year
or 11.317 percent with dividends we
invested
so according to donald trump's story he
destroyed the overall stock market
producing nearly triple the annual
returns however
here's where things get tricky several
reports
show that after digging through trump's
holdings and financials
his father has actually given him much
more throughout his life
now trump may be right in claiming that
he only received 1 million dollars to
start his business
but even if he received no further
direct help
there is no question that he at the very
least inherited much more
after his father passed away the new
york times
has actually posted a phenomenal article
about trump's finances
if you guys are interested but what they
derived at the end of the day
is that trump received 60.7 million
dollars from his dad
not just 1 million however this 60.7
million dollars
was not a lump sum payment in 1975 or
anything like that rather fred trump
supported his son's various losses
and investments throughout the years
pitching in millions here
and there considering that fred trump
died in mid-1999
there were approximately 25 years
between when donald trump entered the
family business
to when fred trump passed away assuming
that the first five years were decently
smooth
as donald trump didn't delve into large
money losing projects till the 1980s
we'll say that the 60.7 million dollars
that fred gave donald
was evenly split over the approximately
20 years
between 1980 and 2000 this comes out to
an
annual infusion of 3.035 million dollars
to figure out the annual growth rate of
this money we can set our growth rate as
the unknown variable
and then we can add together a bunch of
exponential equations
first we of course have the original 1
million dollars
which has 45 years to grow and then we
have 3.035
million dollars coming in each year
after 1980
where each one has one less year to grow
with the last infusion having 15 years
to grow looking at when this graph
intersects with 4 500 millions we'll see
that this occurs at x equals
1.164 in other words
the average growth rate donald trump has
produced between 1975
and 2015 is still 16.4
annually but that's still not quite
accurate
as that's just the money that fred trump
gave donald when he was alive
we still have the inheritance that
donald trump received after his death
when fred trump passed away he left
behind hundreds of millions for his
children
out of which 177.3 million
would find his way to donald trump in
may of 2004.
now that's a lot of money and he
received it all in cash
so we need to keep in mind that it would
take time for him to actually get this
money invested
even if he invested 50 million dollars
of that per year
it would take him three to four years to
actually get that money
working for him however to estimate his
return
conservatively we'll say that he was
able to deploy
all of this money by the end of 2005
which would give him 10 years of growth
adjusting the graphs to reflect this
we'll see
that this doesn't actually affect his
annual return too much
as this inheritance came in so late in
comparison to his investment journey
and as we all know the key to investment
growth
is time which his inheritance didn't
have much of
anyways his annual rate of return even
after accounting for his late
inheritance
still comes out to 15.7 percent but
what if donald trump actually received
more from his father
than the new york times were able to
uncover what if donald trump
actually received 100 million dollars in
assistance between 1980
and 2000 well that comes out to an
annual infusion
of 5 million and donald trump would
actually still maintain an annual growth
rate
of 14.8 percent if we go up to 200
million dollars in assistance
his annual returns actually drop quite
substantially
down to 12.4 percent but that's still
higher than the market
even with the dividends we invested if
we pump up the infusion to 300 million
over those 20 years the annual rate of
return drops at 10.8 percent
which is just under what he would have
received through the s p 500
with the defense reinvested in fact
donald trump would have had to receive
over 600 million dollars over those 20
years
for him to lose to the s p 500 8.166
annual return without dividends
reinvested as a result
considering that donald trump likely
received more than what the new york
times discovered
but also less than 600 million dollars
donald trump's annual return is likely
in the range of 10 to 15 percent
so yes donald trump likely did beat the
market
but not by insane numbers like 20 to 30
percent
as he likes to suggest this conclusion
is supported by the new york times as
well
who estimate that donald trump would
have 1.96 billion dollars today
if he had just invested the money his
father gave him into the s p 500
and as we established at the beginning
of the video
donald trump does have more than 1.96
billion dollars today and over double
that
five years ago so it's safe to conclude
that he did not lose to the market
but at the same time he could have just
laid back
and cashed out of about two billion
dollars by doing nothing
when we're dealing with such large
numbers it's hard to actually understand
how much growth donald trump was
responsible for so
let's scale down the numbers to get a
better understanding if we assume
that donald trump's actual average
annual return was between 10 and 15
at 12.5 percent over 40 years
that comes out to a 111.2x return
as a result if donald trump were to have
started with a more reasonable
average person amount of ten thousand
dollars in the year 1975
and if he was able to invest ten
thousand dollars per year into his
business
with his growth rate of 12.5 percent he
would have had about
10 million dollars in 2015. he likely
would have been able to invest more into
his business
as it started to pick up traction so if
donald trump didn't get any financial
help from his father
and he followed the same path he'd
likely still be looking at an
empire worth tens of millions with the
best case scenario being a few hundred
million
so donald trump likely would not be a
billionaire today
without the assistance he received from
his father however
one major aspect that should be taken
into consideration
is that donald trump didn't grow up
public company like
amazon or microsoft or apple in the tech
sector
rather he was involved in the real
estate sector
and more specifically commercial luxury
real estate
and when it comes to real estate these
returns are actually
extremely impressive if we take a look
at historic housing prices in new york
city between 1974
and 2006 we'll see that for the most
part
the housing market didn't see much
appreciation we did see a nice increase
in the 1980s
but exponential growth in new york city
didn't really start till the year 2000.
over the last 20 years however the
appreciation rate has thrived
with overall appreciation standing at
141 percent
that translates to an annual
appreciation rate of a solid
four and a half percent so in comparison
to real estate appreciation
donald trump actually performed two to
three times better
of course real estate appreciation does
not account for any profit
that he likely got from the buildings
themselves at the end of the day
donald trump did receive significant
help from his father
much more than he admits to however at
the same time
donald trump also deserves more credit
than most people give him
as he did grow his inheritance
exponentially
and he did end up beating the market but
the s p 500
likely would have been much safer and a
more stress-free bet
what do you guys think about trump's
journey comment that down below
also if you guys enjoyed the depth of
the analysis then make sure to drop a
like
and consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and of course consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one